foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm your host Christina Ellis
Ramsey personality joined today by my
co-host and fellow Ramsey personality
George Campbell we're taking your calls
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five let's get to the phones first
up we have Sam calling from Cleveland
Ohio
hey Sam welcome to the show
hey hello thanks for having me hey
thanks for being here how can we help
yeah so I've been um I have a 18 month
old baby um that's in daycare and I've
been struggling with guilt for being a
working mom and I've been torn about
believing my job for the past year and
it's been kind of impacting you know my
home life and my primary fear is just
like I you know I I have a good income
and if I pause some of my our aggressive
financial goals is that going to be okay
to like take that time take a couple
years to be a stay-at-home mom and cause
those aggressive kind of financial goals
we have
well I'm glad you called that's a lot to
process I'm curious a little bit more
about the bigger picture you said we so
um is your husband working yeah
yeah my husband uh Works um he has a
pretty good job as well okay tell us a
little bit more about your financial
goals so it sounds like you have debt
that you're trying to get out of is that
correct
um we paid off our student loans we have
no credit card that we recently paid off
her car
um and I think it's we're we have an
aggressive Financial role of like paying
off our house in five years
um and I know it's like it's not
something we need to do but we've like
after we pay off our debt like we just
want to pay off everything and that's
kind of that mindset has gotten into our
heads and now that
like I I don't know if it's worth to
kind of give that up and we're also like
saving for college and for our um 18
month old so it's it's just like how
like can those things pause and wait for
me to take um a couple years off well
Sam I hear a lot of emotion in your
voice it sounds like yes those goals are
important but that being a stay-at-home
mom also is important how does it kind
of weigh in your head
I don't want to miss the early years but
I'm also I I guess in my family I've
always seen working moms so it's just
this is like a really hard thing to do
for me
um what do you want I mean what do you
want
uh I I want to stay at home but I'm
scared to do it what are you afraid of
so if we take this whole bad mom thing
off the table because either way you're
going to get yelled at right if you're a
working mom if you're a stay-at-home mom
so let's just take that off the table
and and put down the shame and guilt in
the baggage and say what is right for
Sam could you guys live off of your
husband's income
yeah because and then how much longer
would it take to pay off the house
um well I mean we're paying like times
three right now our mortgage payment if
I if I stopped working who would
probably take 10 years 10 years instead
of five
yeah okay so let's walk through a worst
case scenario worst case scenario you
get to have your dream of being a
stay-at-home mom for a few years for as
long as you'd like and you have a
mortgage for five years longer and you
will survive that's a worst case
scenario
how does that sound yeah that's what I'm
seeing on paper obviously taking the
emotion out of it just on on the facts
on paper it's a reasonable situation
there's people who stay at home who are
in much worse Financial situations
drowning in debt and they still make it
work so the fact that you guys have
worked so hard to get to this point
you're allowed to do things like this
without guilt
yeah I guess I'm I'm worried though
still about long term like I have a
really nice 401k plan with my my job
well pausing for a few years and how
will that impact my retirement like it's
not just the mortgage it's just like
having that oh crunch the numbers go
okay if I left my job my 401k sat there
we rolled it to an IRA we continued to
invest that money
what would it turn into
okay it's gonna be a million five
instead of two
big whoop you still get to have the
retirement you want you have those years
with your kid because here's what the
other side is you don't do this you keep
working and you live with regret for the
rest of your life about the years you
could have been with your child that
you'll never have back yeah
we can always get more money we can't
get time back
and you guys have put yourself in such
an incredible financial position to be
able to do this
well in my heart goes out to you because
we we've had this conversation in our
house before where we're talking through
you know the balance between being a
working mom and just absolutely adoring
our kids and there have been times where
we've made sacrifices and maybe pulled
back on a project or not gone as hard at
work because I'm I asked myself that
question you know when I'm 90 years old
when I'm on my deathbed and I look back
am I going to look back and go man we
didn't pay our mortgage off five years
earlier or am I going to be grateful
that I took that time with my kids
and it's like when you go really big
picture of like death but I've seen so
many studies of like people who were
passing away when they were older and
it's like they didn't miss you know the
money we care about money here that's
important we want you to be financially
strong but at the end of the day those
memories with your kids this beautiful
time where they're young like that's
going to be the stuff you remember
yeah
I guess the other fear is that you know
I've worked really hard in my career to
be where I'm at today if I you know take
a few years off what what is that going
to be what's the impact going to be to
my career long term like I feel like I
will be taking steps a couple steps
backwards yes it's worth it but that's
another thought I have do you have any
mentors
uh yeah I do all uh working my like kind
of mom mentors yeah do you have anybody
in your life who has done what you're
thinking about doing where they left the
workforce for a period of time and then
came back and they're crushing it
no and it's kind of frowned upon in my
family because no one had the
opportunity to do it I think that's my
challenge to you today is to find that
woman look for that woman who has left
for a while and has come back and is now
crushing it in their career because I
know we have people at Ramsay who are
directors and who are doing amazing
things here in house who were gone for
10 years to raise their kids and now
they went back in the workforce and
they're doing amazing and there are
thousands millions of women who have
done that I just think that right now
your scope is a bit limited because like
what you what you said your family is
against it women in your in your job
aren't doing it and it's kind of feeling
like a unique path but there have been
tons of women who have done it and done
it successfully
sure sure I don't believe this lie Sam
that you are not going to have any you
know economic worth if you stay at home
for a few years with your kid
um like Christina said the truth is a
lot of people go back to work and who
knows you might even find a better
career when you come back uh if you want
to come back who knows either way
there's no wrong answers here the only
wrong way to do it is to put yourself in
a financial pit that you can't crawl out
of and now you have Financial stress on
top of all this
so you got to deal with the opinions of
family but you know what they worked
hard to raise you so that you could live
the life that you want and this is what
that looks like and it may not be the
opinion you're looking for and it's kind
of a scary leap I think a lot of people
who've been through it will tell you
that they had those fears too and it's
kind of nerve-wracking but I know that
I've talked to a lot of the women here
and they didn't regret it we're wishing
you well Sam we'll be right back this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com time
to save up to 45 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
we're taking your calls at triple eight
eight two five five two two five got
something on your mind you just want
some friends to bounce it off of give us
a call we're excited to talk to you next
up we have Amy calling from Dallas Texas
hey Amy welcome to the show
thank you hey how can we help I try to
be relatively quick I think but um I've
been investing now for about 13 maybe 12
years and I did my calculation I have
about an eight percent return so far
should I be discouraged by that or
should I kind of think you know we're in
kind of a downturn and overall it should
end up still being cut
well good job with that 13 years are you
completely out of debt
yeah they just have seven awesome oh
that's awesome so what is your net worth
as of today
uh 2.2 million I think maybe I think
you're going to be fine you know I think
you're gonna be I wouldn't be
discouraged with a 2.2 million I asked
George because one percent when I look
when I'm 65 is a huge amount of money oh
yeah I mean a one percent swing you're
saying under over if you get nine
percent instead of eight percent it
changes the numbers drastically Yeah by
like 15 million dollars and so you're
worried am I going to have enough
is that really the heart of the question
that's not that's not really the
question really the question is because
Dave says numerous times I should
average 10 to 12. well it's not that you
should it's just if you look at the S P
500 since you know the 1920s and 30s the
average return has been now there's been
times where it's been down 30 percent
there's been times where it's up 30 and
so I would not be discouraged by looking
at a snapshot of even 12 years and
looking at that because you're investing
over more like a 30-year period right
true and even a 30-year period getting
eight percent you're still going to be
wildly wealthy comparatively to if you
didn't invest
sure and so I I don't I don't look at it
in snapshots because you're right if I
looked at my 401k for the last year I'm
gonna throw up when you see negative 16
negative 18 it hurts your heart when
you're like I'm dumping money into this
and the number is going down it's going
the opposite way right
yes and so I encourage you to you can
look at it every so often but the fact
that you're here with a 2.2 million net
worth at what age are you
33 at 33 years old is mind-boggling your
husband's 32 yes how did you guys get
there because most people are going is
Amy crazy because she's saying she
should she be discouraged and here she
is with two million dollars at 33 years
old
Never End baby step two I never had any
debt okay right you just avoided that
completely and what age did you start
investing
as soon as I got out of college 2011.
okay and that was 12 years ago and
beyond that has anything else changed
did you get an inheritance
no
this was all just 401K your house your
cars
yes sir what do you all do for a living
uh surprise surprise we're both
Engineers love it love it hey how are
you invested right now what are you
investing in
um so right now it's a mix between
personal residence 401K
um my company stock which I am
diversifying
um just gradually
um and obviously Roth IRAs so and are
those in mutual funds index funds
um I mean many mutual funds
um I don't yeah I mean
ETFs sometimes but not for I mean it's
still I do 10 you know track record over
10 years and all the all those things do
you have an advisor a financial advisor
I do I do that's why I'm like wondering
it's always my fault right I'm not going
to blame him but I'd like should I make
any changes
well I mean it wouldn't hurt to get a
second opinion we've got great
smartvestors if you want to sit down
with them you can find them on the
Ramsey Solutions website but it is nice
to sit down just to double check to make
sure that they're investing your money
well
have you thought about getting a second
opinion
yes and you know obviously I I'm always
learning right so I'm always and and
it's you know as we said it's him giving
him advising me and I make the final
decision so it's always my choice of
what I am investing and obviously I
don't ever invest in anything that I
don't actually understand so that's why
I'm well if you want some encouragement
just look at history you can go look at
charts of the S P 500 over the last you
know Decades of years and I'm looking at
it right now and I'm saying okay
actually out of the last 12 years we
were only down two years and here's what
you're looking at 2022 we were down 18
which is skewing your average number
isn't it exactly and I am like I am an
engineer so and so 20 years from now
we're gonna have way more up years than
down years if you just look at it
historically and that's going to change
that average number so I wouldn't focus
on that average number and lose sleep
over that specific number because it's
not really an accurate representation
what we're trying to tell people is over
the course of time your entire career
your money is going to grow at a
significantly higher rate than if you
don't invest or you invest in something
super volatile gosh this is such a great
question though way to go Amy that's
amazing I love just the level of
ownership you have over and the fact
that you're continuing to ask questions
I'll just anybody anybody at 32 who has
2.2 million dollars is just incredible
those would be the people going I'm a
little discouraged by my eight percent
return I'm like that's the kind of
nerdery that will lead you to wealth and
keep a way to go awesome all right up
next we have Brian calling from Boston
hey welcome to the show
hi oh is it Brynn okay we thought we
lost a vowel there we did good to have
you
how can we help
um so uh my husband and I are looking to
see what we should do with
um would saving up money and we're
trying to see if we should focus on
paying our mortgage off
or if we should put up a garage
apartment on a property because that
would create a rental income that would
help us pay the mortgage faster
how much is this Edition going to cost
so it be roughly any
what's left on the mortgage
000. do you have the money right now to
do the addition
no we're saving towards that we don't
have that right now okay about how far
are you from that
we don't if we really just started doing
everything about a month ago starting
January 2023 is when we just sort of
okay cast The Vision
yeah we have right now in savings we
don't have a separate savings outside of
our we have a fully funded
six-month emergency fund
and
aside from that then we also have uh
Savings of
um what the mortgage payments will be
for this year in an account that we're
going to
use
okay you have one year worth of mortgage
payments sitting in another savings
account
yes and what's that for
that is for the mortgage for this year
because our income is really
it goes up and down
okay yeah yeah the bartender so well I'm
from Boston people drink year-round
there I've seen it yeah
not a very seasonal
it's really busy where we live okay
could you do something in the winter
time to supplement it
yeah so that's what
um we're looking to do this year
um and then I have in November we'll
probably make another 30 000 I have an
Etsy shop so usually
I'll do about that in November okay well
Brent mathematically I don't think it's
wise to build this Edition right now I
think if you look at it on paper and you
take 80 to 100 Grand and throw it at the
mortgage instead of putting it into an
addition that you then need to Roi on
you need to get the return on this
investment which is going to take a long
time in addition to helping you pay down
the mortgage so I'm taking what's in
that account with those mortgage
payments on top of this extra 30 on top
of your income and let's just focus on
this house and later on once it's paid
off if you want to build that Edition
for some extra income we do that in cash
flowing that's good what do you think
Christina I'm with you and there's just
the factor of being a landlord and
having somebody else live on your
property there's a lot that goes into it
and we've taken so many calls recently
with people who are doing remodels that
cost a lot more than they anticipated to
begin with so there's also just that
factor of the unknown and the time it'll
take I say lean into that momentum and
keep going we'll be right back this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five all right
George I want to talk about something
that is really hot in the news now and
it's gonna keep going up in the next few
weeks
student loan forgiveness you've been
keeping up with the latest hottest
trending student loan forgiveness news
so spicy gosh well I know a lot of you
out there are feeling like it's pretty
spicy because this really affects a lot
of people a lot of people have been
having these questions for so long this
pause has been kicked down the road so
many times for a while everybody was
celebrating you know hitting pinatas
thinking their loans were going to be
forgiven and then it's like the other
direction so I've just talked to so many
people who are confused and overwhelmed
and just waiting to see how this case
this is a classic will there won't they
what a tease this is like Tom Brady's
career you know are you gonna retire or
not man
all right so the updates two court cases
will begin arguments with the Supreme
Court or in the Supreme Court on
February 28th so next Tuesday that's
when things finally take center stage
and the courts should technically make a
decision by the end of June now okay so
this is kind of how it's supposed to
play out in each case the suing party
has to First establish standing
basically showing that somehow this
program adversely affects them so they
have to prove that before the case moves
forward now these cases one case is
brought by several States and the other
is by individuals and I think the states
are saying that it like affects their
taxes negatively and the individuals are
basically like hey we have loans too and
so they're trying to strike the
Forgiveness down and so they have to
prove they have a case to do this they
have to prove they have a case over the
next few months so let's say they do
that it moves forward now the Biden
Administration is trying to use the
heroes act to justify moving forward
with the Forgiveness now the heroes act
it basically says that the president has
power to make changes during a crisis
without Congressional approval that
feels like a pretty
squishy loophole right and that's that's
what a lot of experts are saying that's
kind of the argument authority to make
changes versus like here's a trillion
dollars in student loan forgiveness
feels like a jump well and that's part
of the challenges is like they've
declared that the pandemic is over and
yet they're saying that because of the
pandemic we're now going to use we're
going to do student loan forgiveness
which a lot of people are saying that
feels political it feels like a way to
kind of push a political agenda forward
when this doesn't really Target people
who had coveted right like they're
saying it's because of covid but it
doesn't Target people who have coven so
anyways it's just it's interesting
because we could have these arguments
all day about like is it right is it
wrong
um and what what do we feel about
forgiveness is it fair all of those
arguments but that's not really the
Supreme Court's job their job is to
decide if this version of forgiveness is
legal or not and whether or not this is
an overreach of Presidential Power juicy
stuff so they're not going like does
this pass the vibe check they're going
does this pass like the Constitutional
Vibe check right exactly well and it's
super important I'm trying to really
bring it down for Gen Z okay Christina
and really for me to understand it
that's the truth
well it's important because it also
sends for future cases about what the
president has power to do or not I know
a lot of people are rooting for it to go
through but it's also important to think
about the long-term impact about that of
that because it's like a future
president could then decide something
that you don't like so it's a little
spicy George it'll be interesting to see
how it plays out especially with the
future implications okay so what are the
outcomes that could happen there are
three major possible outcomes so one is
that it shot down early basically the
parties can't establish standing and the
cases are dismissed and this would
basically clear the way for the program
to move forward but it wouldn't prevent
other cases from being filed so
technically somebody a temporary win for
the Biden Administration to go all right
we got that one down now we gotta hope
no one else comes after us exactly stop
this thing somebody else could sue and
then we could be back in this mess again
of like waiting for the next trial date
to see what happens okay another option
is that the case moves forward and the
program is deemed legal and this would
clear the way for the Biden
Administration to move forward with full
loan forgiveness and then the third
option is that the case moves forward
and loan forgiveness is struck down and
then that would be back to the drawing
board for Biden and forgiveness would
likely not happen back to square one
back to square one so basically all this
being said is that I think there's been
a lot of hype about next week the case
is starting you know it's going before
The Supreme Court on the 28th but it 'd
be a while before we really know what's
going to happen like this is just the
baby beginning phases and I know that's
hard to hear if you are sitting there
waiting and have been waiting literally
for years to figure out what's going to
happen like that's kind of frustrating
hearing that but it is hopefully we will
have something by June 30th and
basically if we don't have like an
official set outcome by June 30th then
student loan payments are supposed to
begin 60 days after that so it's either
the cases ruled and payments begin 60
days after the case is closed or 60 days
after June 30th but Biden could extend
the pause again right that's always a
possibility that's always taking the can
down the road I mean I have been shocked
several times in this whole process
several times I'm like surely not
there's no way it's going to be extended
again and I continue to be so you wish
we could extend things in our life like
the term papers do I'm like now I'm
going to need another extension teach
right or like hey my taxes are due I'm
gonna I'm gonna kick that down another
few months if you don't mind IRS or a
couple years it'll be nice you know so
is this going to be televised like
C-SPAN level like can we watch this I
mean for entertainment I don't know I
don't know that many people want to
watch every detail the court case but
maybe we all watch the Johnny Depp Amber
Heard trial okay and that took way
longer than this and that was a lot less
money on the line we were talking
Millions this is billions and billions
of dollars billions and billions of
dollars but I know we've been saying
this all along
with all this forgiveness stuff there's
so much anxiety around it there's so
much frustration and if you want to
really get rid of some of that anxiety
start working on paying them off take
control don't wait on Washington to
figure out what they're doing because we
have seen it's been quite a hot mess the
last few years and that being said I
know I mentioned it last week if you're
like hey I want to hedge my bets and
wait to see if forgiveness is going to
happen because it's right around the
corner then act like you're paying these
loans off and start putting that money
in a high yield savings account so that
if for some reason it does or doesn't go
through you are ready to pay off these
loans regardless but we've been
preaching you know keep your eyes
focused on getting these loans
completely done that is a good word
goodness gracious yeah it's a lot y'all
what a mess we are with you and hoping
this passes soon all right let's go to
the phones next up we have Hamza calling
from Washington DC hey hanza
hey welcome how can we help
oh thank you um I just had a question I
was hoping you guys should help me out
um I just finished paying off my student
loans it was about 11k
uh so now uh all I have left is my card
debt and my credit card debt I have
enough right now
um if I were to withdraw my savings and
stocks to pay off my credit card debt
but I was wondering if that's the best
choice or if I should just keep those in
steady growth stocks right now I have
them in
um boo it's a Vanguard S P 500 so next
one
well I love your heart for investing but
I I want you to have a bigger heart for
debt Freedom right now and we can get
back to investing way more once we free
up those payments
yeah that's exactly what I was thinking
I was just what's your credit card
interest rate
uh credit card interest rate it is about
I believe it's
us it's between four different credit
cards I think the it ranges from 15 up
to 24. and you're thinking is I can
invest and maybe make eight percent
instead of paying 24 the math isn't math
on this I'm using all the money I'm
cashing out the stocks obviously be
aware of the tax implications of that if
you've had gains make sure you have that
set aside to pay that man I'm paying all
this off today you're gonna sleep
differently tonight when you don't have
payments in the world and that's what
I've been accomplished uh contemplating
all week and then today I was writing
out my financials and I was like well
should I pay it off today and then I
figured why not call you guys to help me
make that decision I love it absolutely
pay it off today and you know I love
that you have the investing muscle
already there that tells me you're going
to build wealth so much faster once you
don't have debt in your life cut up the
cards don't look back don't worry about
the credit score there's all kinds of
ways you can live life without the
credit score so if you're worried about
that piece don't be we've got tons of
resources on that my fine print episode
all about the dirty truth behind the
credit score and one on credit card
rewards there's just no reason to keep
them around
you were gonna breathe much easier
tomorrow we're excited for you we'll be
right back this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five hey guys if
you are wondering whether to buy or sell
a home this year here's what you need to
know about the housing market there's
still more demand for homes than there
are homes to buy and the median home
price is expected to keep Rising just at
a slower rate it's just cooling off and
interest rates likely haven't stopped
going up so what does that mean for you
well if you're buying a home you're
still going to be facing some
competition out there and big price tags
and if you want to sell your home
chances are you can still make a nice
profit but you have to be patient for
the right offer to come your way so of
course that all depends on where you are
every Market is going to be different
and it's why you need to work with an
experienced real estate agent when
you're ready to start the home buying or
selling process you want someone who's
done this hundreds of times before and
knows exactly how to negotiate a strong
deal based on the current market in your
location you can find agents like that
who are Ramsay trusted through our
endorsed local providers program these
are the top performing agents around the
country who we trust to serve you well
if you want to get connected with one
today just go to ramseysolutions.com
agent that's ramseysolutions.com agent
all right let's go back to the phones up
next we have Michaela calling from Santa
Rosa California hey Michaela welcome to
the show
hi Christina and George thanks for
taking my call hey thanks for calling
how can we help
so my husband and I got married at the
end of last this last year just a few
months ago congratulations
um
thank you we're on baby step 3B slash
four
um we both were investing debt-free with
an emergency fund before we got married
now we want to focus on saving up for a
house being in California we want to at
least have a hundred thousand dollars
for a down payment which will take us at
least two and a half to three years
currently with our incomes we make
together about 125 000 a year but are
expecting for that to increase slightly
in the next few years at least
um and so we're just on the fence about
whether we fully stop investing and I
know you guys say to do that if it's if
you're going to be buying house the next
three years or saving for a down payment
the next three years but
um just not sure if we should decrease
it stop it all together missing out on
interest in the next or compound
interest the next three years seems like
a lot we're both 31 so just wanted to
keep that in mind awesome well you guys
are plenty young and here's the other
side of that if you pause investing yes
you'll lose out on that compound
interest but if you keep investing and
you slide on the home purchase well the
home prices are a continual moving
Target in California and so you might be
now buying a house that is 50 Grand more
because you waited another year so on
either side you feel like you're being
crunched by time
yeah exactly that's why we just wanted
your advice yeah so if I'm in your shoes
I mean you could split the difference
you might go we're going to pause
investing for a year or two but then
begin investing and keep saving for the
down payment yeah that's good have you
kind of done you said it's two and a
half to three years at the current rate
to get to your 100K have you kind of
mapped out what it would look like if
you did what with like what George said
where you kind of either do it you know
one to two years of savings and then
start investing or kind of played with
different scenarios
yes we've already decreased our
investing down to about seven percent
just to have more money to be stocking
up on the side for a house that's about
eight hundred dollars a month um that we
are investing so that would be 800 a
month we can put more towards saving a
house so if you did that then what would
the time trajectory be
um like if you knew that that would save
another 25
000 in three years or just under three
years so it would cut it down probably
about a year okay well that's it was
three years of eight hundred dollars
from doing the math correctly but
man it's it's
how much do you have an employer match
with your retirement plans
I don't but my husband has a three
percent match so we'd keep that okay so
you'd invest up to the match on his end
yeah I mean you could split the
difference if you don't want if you want
to have a little bit of both have the
cake and eat it too you could invest
let's say you know five to ten percent
and still have a little bit more margin
on the down payment side to get there
faster okay there's not really a right
or wrong answer here it's kind of just
running those numbers and saying yeah
what's going to be the best scenario for
y'all and there may even be like the
option of so you make 125 total
um do y'all is that just 40 hours a week
full time for each of you
yeah I have the opportunity for some
overtime
um he doesn't but he's also more likely
to get significant raises in the next
few years where I'm not because I have a
County job so
well I would focus on increasing the
income
um that would be my goal personally is
to invest 15 save up for the down
payment and make up the difference by
making more money and that way okay you
kind of have the best of both worlds
where you're still investing you've got
the down payment you still will hit your
goal of two and a half to three years so
I would rather look at making more money
first before pausing all investing
yeah that's such a good question though
I think a lot of people have that and I
know some of you are listening right now
and you're like baby step three B
there's a b there's a B I thought there
was just seven
um so if you're a new listener and
you're kind of like what are all these
baby steps or what does 3B
um we've got something set up on Ramsey
Solutions called get started so you just
go to the website ramseysolutions.com
and click on the get started button and
we'll help you figure out the best next
step on your financial Journey based on
exactly where you are that's
ramsaysolutions.com get started all
right up next we have Cameron calling
from Charlotte North Carolina hey
Cameron welcome to the show
hey thanks so much hope you guys are
doing well we're doing
um awesome awesome so bench step four
active duty military
uh what are the correct
um or the best percentage allotments for
the Cs and iPhone and the tsp assuming
that it was still the ones that you guys
must have in and then secondly
um is it just set forget after that I
mean that's why I set those percentages
and maintained them throughout as I get
promoted to get razors so I just said
forget
um can you talk directly on the phone I
missed the second half the question I
think I caught it all but we're getting
a little Kermit on the line there well
first of all thank you for your service
Cameron that's that's incredible and
you're talking about the tsp uh which is
the military's version of like a 401k
Cameron do you have a Roth option with
the tsp
yes that's the one I've chosen great
okay and you're spot on so for those
listening you're going what is he
talking about the CSI so this is not a
crime scene investigation there are a
bunch of different funds that you have
within the tsp there's G fund f fund C
fund s fund and I fund and Dave has
recommended for years to stick to those
last three the c s and I so that's
common stock investment small cap stock
index investment and then International
stock index investment and so to get to
the
funds that mirror what Dave would
recommend four types of mutual funds you
want CSI and the split that we now
recommend and have for a while now is 80
10 and 10. so 80 in the C fund which is
tied to the S P 500 that's where you
want the majority of your investing 10
in the S fund which includes stocks from
these kind of small to mid-sized
companies that have higher risk but also
higher return a little more aggressive
and then finally that last 10 percent
into the international fund which has
the overseas companies and is a good
hedge against the U.S market taking a
dip
and yes Cameron I would stick with that
all the way through
I wouldn't slow it down if you want to
slow it down
um you know you could do 60 in the C
fund 20 and the S fund 20 in the iPhone
if you wanted a different split but I
think the 80 10 10 is going to get you a
great retirement
copy okay thank you guys so much yeah my
main question
oh thank you for my life and I'm so
thankful for y'all man that means the
world well again thank you for your
sacrifice and your service and it is
that simple a lot of people they want to
keep you know kind of moving their
Investments around and yes as you get
closer to retirement a lot of the
financial planning Community says hey
you should really shift these over to
bonds but the problem with that is if
you retire for 30 Years Christina and
now you're shifted into bonds you're
going to see a much much smaller return
because of the less aggressive portfolio
yep so for now I know I'm gonna you know
retire for potentially 10 20 30 years I
want to stay aggressive so that I
continue to get those returns they got
me here that's so good it's good to keep
the full picture in mind it's so easy to
get laser focused on a small part of it
but I love that and I just love the
Simplicity of it I love that even his
question was like wow it's that simple
yeah I think I think a lot of times with
money especially investing it feels
overwhelming and over complicated and I
think especially now with everything in
the market and everybody is a guru
there's just such an overwhelm but a lot
of times this money stuff even if you've
never invested before a lot of it can be
simple when you learn foundational
principles absolutely and that Roth
option uses after tax money that grows
tax-free and so if you have a million
bucks in the Roth account you have a
million dollars and you don't have to
give Uncle Sam any of it
anything you already did you go that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show and
the books we'll be back soon until next
time this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Christina Ellis if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm your host Christina Ellis
joined today by my co-host George
Campbell and we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five if you've got questions about
student loan forgiveness how to pay off
debt going to college debt free anything
that's on your mind if you just need a
second opinion somebody to talk through
it with give us a call let's go to the
phones for a step we have Jessica
calling from San Francisco California
hey Jessica welcome to the show
hi thank you for taking my question
we're happy you're here how can we help
so my husband and I are renting an Inuit
house from families but due to her
drowning in debt our utilities are
constantly threatening to be shut off
due to her not paying the bills should
we stay and continue to take advantage
of the great Runway and save faster for
a down payment or move and pay
significantly more and our saving gets
slowed and stalled drastically okay tell
us more about the situation this sounds
pretty dramatic so have the lights been
shut off yet
um no uh in the past I would since the
beginning of the year I would say we've
had
um three different
um threats of either the PG e and or
water being shut off what's your
relationship like with this relative
[Music]
oh
tough so then we've got a whole marriage
Dynamic right so how does your yeah how
does your husband feel about this
so my husband is a very loving soul and
he wants to fix everyone's problems
um but we we can't fix this problem for
her um so I mean we've come to her and
said you know we're willing to pay a
little bit more in rent
um but our conditions are she has to get
on to the Dave Ramsey plan and we're
willing to help her with that but she
doesn't want to one of the conversations
been like when you say hey uh we would
love to you know have electricity and
water could you I don't know keep up
with your bills how does she take that
um well she feels insecure
um because the rules are reversed right
your parents are supposed to take care
and Mentor your kids not the other way
around
well she's not doing a good job taking
care of her son in this case if that's
the if that's the attitude she has
towards it
um you know both sides are struggling
here so what does she does she not have
the money is she just
misbehaving when it comes to her
spending what do you think the actual
root of this is
um so I think the root of it is
um you know recently she's been going
through a pretty sticky divorce and so
that's been consuming a lot of money in
attorney fees she also doesn't have a
job and we've been trying to help her
pursue that route because she needs more
of an income and she just is not willing
to do it
um so so is your rent basically floating
her life and covering her mortgage
um basically so right now she's in a
situation where um the only thing she is
responsible for are the utilities and
her personal
um her personal
finances because her ex-ish husband is
still paying the mortgage so luckily we
don't have the mortgage as a threat but
so where does your rent payment go
that is an excellent question I would
love to know that myself because he's
just paying does he live there too who's
living in this in this place you said
it's in unit
um yeah so it's there's it's a large
property so there's the primary house
that you would see from the street and
then in the back half of the property
there is a whole separate unit that's
like an unit a one bed one bath so
that's what we live in who's in the
primary
um just her so my mother-in-law and then
her special needs son
so what's going to happen with this
divorce with the property
because I was smart enough to get a
lease that protects us from that so
you're going to be leasing from her
ex-husband at that point yes so we'll
just change who we pay from that I feel
like that would change the dynamic with
my landlord
drastically
yeah this this whole situation sounds a
little Jerry Springer and not not very
fun if I'm in your shoes I'm getting out
like this this is pretty toxic as is and
I think you know that but I'm sure it's
complicated so if your husband this is
his mom and you said he's the nicest
Soul he wants to help her when you've
thrown out the idea of hey maybe we
should move somewhere else how does he
take that
I think that his primary concern right
now is that he really really wants to
leave but he wants to do so he wants to
move into our first home is his thing
but being in California in the Bay Area
that's that's tough to do without a
sizable down payment so that's kind of
where we're stuck in between so how much
money do you guys have right now
so right now that we could pay
comfortably in a down payment we
probably have like thirty five thousand
dollars
okay and what are the what's a home
price you'd be looking at in that area
in this area homes start
um at roughly 550 thousand dollars okay
and what are you paying in rent right
now to your mother-in-law right now it's
great I pay about a thousand dollars a
month okay and you said it's a one it's
a one bedroom
yeah one bedroom I mean we couldn't find
anything else
sure household income
about
I would say probably 90 000 a year
okay well living in the Bay Area I would
assume you guys are going to have to up
that income
yeah before you even get out of there
and so that would be A1 is let's up the
income so that when we do get out and
rent maybe double uh we can still float
it so I don't think we're quite ready
for home ownership I would sign a lease
for six to 12 months at the next place
while you continue to save up the down
payment and get the income up I don't
know they're going to be able to make a
leap immediately from this place into
Home Ownership that feels scary to take
on you know four or five hundred
thousand dollars making ninety well
George if you're in her shoes what would
you do would you go ahead and just take
higher rent and live somewhere else or
stay I would have an exit strategy if we
can't now we don't when is the divorce
going to be settled do we know
I mean it's been going on for four years
so it could be another year so when is
your Lisa yeah
uh my lease is up in a year and a half
oh wow that's a long lease well I would
have an exit strategy so that when if
things keep going south we can get out
easily and hopefully you can get out of
this lease right are you stuck in this
lease I am not stuck in this Leaf well
and I'm assuming with the fact that
they're literally having issues with
their utilities there's got to be some
way to get out of it if they can't
provide basic yeah why why aren't the
utilities in the ex-husband's name and
he takes care of it if he's taking care
of the mortgage
um because he didn't want to I mean he
doesn't live there and so he's like I'll
pay for the mortgage because he does he
has a construction uh business on the
back half of the property so he still
needs access to the property but he
doesn't want to pay for getting money or
I would have an emergency family meeting
with everyone involved as messy as it
may be and go listen we're in the middle
of this nightmare we need a solution
here we need someone to pay the bills on
time
be adults I know divorce is hard and
messy but you guys are in the middle of
this thing too and you have to take care
of yourselves financially so I'm getting
an exit strategy and getting out of
there and that means getting the income
up and saying bye bye to this weird
ex-husband mortgage situation I'm with
you George we'll be right back this is
the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five
all right y'all I know a lot of you guys
have questions about taxes it's tax
season I know I can feel a lot of people
breathing a little heavier just thinking
about it we get it taxes are confusing
but to help you get a better handle on
them let's unpack one of the questions
that we got from one of our listeners
they wrote what's the difference between
a tax deduction and a tax credit this is
Juicy stuff Christina the stuff they
didn't teach you in high school they
were like Pythagorean theorem here's
When the War of 1812 happened spoiler
1812 but they didn't teach you about
taxes and so this is a common uh
confusing point with taxes what is the
difference between a deduction and a
credit so let's go through this real
quick a deduction lowers your taxable
income
and so you simply subtract the deduction
from your income and that is what the
government sees that you actually owe
taxes on
now credit on the other hand is actually
a dollar for dollar discount on what you
owe so let's say you do your taxes your
income was 70 grand at the end of the uh
tax return you owe a thousand well a 500
credit Will slash your bill down to 500
bucks left and so the credits are
awesome because it's discounting that
final total the deduction is lowering
the taxable income and there's tons of
deductions and credits out there on the
deduction side you've heard of the
standard deduction which is what most
people do it doesn't make sense to
itemize for a lot of people medical
deductions charitable deductions
business deductions and then credits
you've heard this one because the
pandemic the Earned Income Tax Credit
the child tax credit
there are some education credits
dependent care credits and so those are
all really good to look into and if you
want more tax tips like that in software
that helps you file on your own with
confidence you can head to
ramseysolutions.com
Smart tax it's just 19.95 right now to
file your federal return online and
there is no hidden fees like the other
guys there's no sneaky offers they're
going to put you into debt just go to
ramseysolutions.com smart tax that's a
good explanation George and I think it's
so true these are so many things that we
wish we would have learned in high
school but you get out in the real world
and when you try to look up taxes a lot
of times the stuff is so confusing well
it takes you to the IRS website which
bless them not the simplest explanation
a lot of the time right so we've tried
to make it simple for regular people
just trying to do their taxes and get
through this season all right let's go
back to the phones next up we have Sam
calling from Charlotte North Carolina
hey Sam welcome to the show
hey how you doing hey we're doing well
what's up
well uh I'm at a point where I'm kind of
starting over uh went through a divorce
a few years ago
and I feel like I'm kind of behind a
little bit
um I'm 39. I'm just now starting to
probably I would say make a pretty
decent salary
and but uh on the good side I paid down
a lot of my debt I only have probably
like five or maybe six thousand dollars
worth of debt
and uh the comment I work for they do
give me a 401k on the uh what is the
black Ross uh I mean Black Rock um 401k
plan okay that uh I was listening to
y'all to Max it out so I've been doing
that but what I'm stuck at is
um I'm renting an apartment right now of
about 1300 a month
but I'm about a few more months my lease
if you haven't I'm trying to decide
should I buy a home because like it's
just me I don't have any kids anything
it's just me but did I still going to
get a home and I'm going to settle down
in something that I sort of like and
just get started tackling on that
mortgage or should I get a home is more
of an investment to build I guess
wealth or income
how much money do you have in the bank
right now
well actually the thing right now I'll
probably have probably about five
thousand dollars but
um in my 401k I have close to 50. okay
so let we're not going to touch the 401K
because that you're going to get
hammered with penalties as well as taxes
on that so we're going to ignore that
we're going to pretend that is money
locked away until you actually retire so
aside from that you have five thousand
dollars to your name
yeah okay and you said you have 6 000 in
debt left
yeah and I'm going to get like maybe
like a two thousand dollar
um income tax return good so that would
leave you with about seven thousand in
the bank
yeah okay and how much are you investing
right now percentage-wise of your income
um well the company I worked for um
Frito-Lay they uh right now they're
matching me is four percent but I'm
putting in like
12 but on their website it suggested I
should be putting in 15 okay
well the man they must be following the
Ramsay plan encouraging people to invest
15 which is what you should do once you
are out of debt with a fully funded
emergency fund and so you are not quite
there you're close man once you get that
uh that tax refund you're going to be
able to pay off all of your debt in one
day
right yeah yeah and I think that's what
I was thinking that but I just felt like
you know like man I'm 39 I'm supposed
already be you know 300 000 in the
savings of course I already have a house
I'm you know what I'm saying opinion man
you gotta run your own race Sam I know
you feel like you're behind you've been
through it man you got knocked down with
that divorce and that's okay but the
goal now is not to make it look like
you're ahead the goal is to actually get
ahead and that means getting out of debt
and getting a fully funded emergency
fund first well and sometimes whenever
we kind of feel that shame and we feel
that frustration that we're not further
along we can be more likely to try to
rush things when we're not quite ready
and you're not quite ready to buy a home
you're not far from it you'll be there
soon but like George said you know we
want to do this the right way we want to
build wealth that's really really going
to last so I know right now it's gonna
feel like we're asking you to kind of
take a step backwards and you know pause
investing pay off that debt get your
fully funded emergency fund and then
invest but this is just going to be for
a brief season then so that when you
have when you move forward with
investing you have a really strong
foundation and also when you buy that
house you know you gotta at least five
percent down hopefully closer to twenty
percent down you know we want to buy the
house the right way so I would first
kind of work through the emotions and
the you know just that feeling of I'm
behind I gotta hurry I gotta hurry and
get ahead because that can set you off
course Sam what's your income
uh I'm a truck driver a local I may last
I made about 80 about 88 nine awesome we
have a great income there and so here's
the plan pause investing for a season
you're gonna go down to zero percent
it's gonna hurt but it's gonna light a
fire under you and it's gonna give you
more money in your bank account to get
through these baby steps so your next
goal after that you want a thousand
dollars in the bank you have that any
other money we're throwing it at that
debt it's gonna be gone real soon and
then we will have no payments we'll have
a thousand bucks in the bank and we're
going to add to that with a three to six
month emergency fund what does that look
like for you maybe 15 grand
yeah honestly uh I have one other thing
I want to throw at you um I do ask you
guys
and I owe um I haven't paid off early
but I don't know 748 left on it okay but
I do got high mileage on it but it's an
Infinity but I mean it's still running
great
but
I guess we'll you know I was thinking
like you know don't jump out there and
get another car payment
and then I'm you know I wanted a
mortgage but like in the Charlotte
marking I mean market like
you do feel the pressure her up and get
something because they make you feel
like price is going to jump so much
every month you wait so that's why I was
feeling like you know the pressure well
the price doesn't matter if you're
hanging on to that car so why not just
pay it off today and just drive it until
the wheels fall off
yeah who are you trying to impress
myself
well you know I'd be impressed if Sam
gets out of debt and stays out of debt
and starts to build for his new future
for Sam not for anyone else yeah and so
I know it's going to take longer you're
behind other people but you're further
ahead than other people and so the truth
is who gives a rats you know what about
this situation
you need to do what's right for you Sam
and that is pause investing get out of
the deck get the emergency fund you know
what to do but it's hard to do it all
with Focus intensity well in picture 10
year 10 years from now saying I make
that guy proud like don't have that guy
be calling the show because he's got
twenty thousand dollars left on his car
loan and he's frustrated because he's
not actually where he wants to go this
Sam has the potential to really be way
further ahead in 10 years so focus on
that guy we're rooting for you we'll be
right back this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five all right
it's time for our question of the day
today's question comes from Peter in
Tennessee
my wife bought five horses using credit
cards without my knowledge while I was
out of the country oh we've reconciled
after that Rocky stage in our marriage
and we decided to sell the horses she
sold three of the horses but now one of
the two remaining horses is sick she
argues that we need to restore the
horse's health so that we are able to
sell it she bought the horse for five
thousand dollars and hopes to sell it
for two thousand dollars if it's healthy
I would like to euthanize the horse but
my wife doesn't have a problem going
into more debt to save it how do we
Define a limit on expenses for the
horse's recovery after which if he
doesn't get well we can just decide for
euthanasia oh my goodness George are you
sweating I have assorted past with horse
related questions on the show Christina
if you all know I I took a call a long
while ago with Rachel and I told the
girl to sell the horse that call is like
legendary now yeah and so to get this is
not a trolling like this someone
actually sent this question and this is
not trolling from the booth guys
um and
it listen I will say this horse people
there's two kinds they're either very
wealthy or they're broke and this is
like an addiction level yeah you know
what I mean if this was good you
probably would say you have a problem
so they're trying to get out of this
mess obviously I am not a part of the
equestrian Community I did look up
obviously options for this and here's my
take I don't think they should sink
money into this thing and I don't think
they should euthanize the horse I think
there's another option let's hear it
George because there's what they're
saying is hey should we sink another
five grand into the horse to get it back
on its hooves
and sell it for two so either way
they're losing a ton of money on this my
option would be why don't we try to
market the horse privately or look into
horse rescues that would be willing to
take this horse on and help it recover
yes that's good that's good that's a
that's a good in between spot where it's
like no more depth and obviously we can
all agree euthanasia is a worst worst
latch lash ditch option right not the
option we want to go with if we can get
the horse on his feet without sinking
too much money into one George you
actually love animals I feel like you
got a lot of hate from horse gate but
you actually
friendship and don't want the horse to
to die absolutely so yes if you are if
you're a gun hoe about trying to help
this horse recover I would set a limit
and say listen let's get a let's get an
estimate from the vet and if we're
willing to do that and we're willing to
cash flow it meaning we're not going to
go more further into debt for this then
I would look into the recovery but if
you're gonna have to go into more debt
we're getting rid of the horse and
giving it to someone who can financially
take care of it that's good I feel like
that's a win-win that's a win-win on
that and then I would also recommend you
all go through FPU again Financial Peace
University because it sounds like you
all worked through some of the marriage
issues you know you sold horses and all
of that but that that desire to still go
into debt is still there with your wife
she hasn't had that I've had it moment
the fact that she's you know kind of
immediately going to oh well let's just
you know spend money on a credit card to
help heal the horse like that's just
that's not a strong foundation so I
would work through that maybe even
consider going through some Financial
coaching
um because yeah there's been there's
been a lot that's happened in your
marriage that trust that was breached is
the most pressing matter in this whole
situation yeah hard to repair well and
it's hard to see once again you know
you've been through so much with the
fact that she went into debt for the
horses to begin with and now she's
immediately going hey here's an issue
let's go into debt again like that's got
to kind of spark something on the inside
yeah but George Force problems I think
that everybody needs a little bit of an
update on horses oh my goodness do I
have an update for you so we just did a
Building Wealth event in Indianapolis
and Katie who is the person that called
in with the horse call who I told to
sell her horse and I said worse things
was at the event she drove five hours to
be at the event and we're we're cool
we've messaged on Instagram I love
getting updates from her she was awesome
and our social team was there and they
made a little clip and so if you're
listening on radio it'll be hard to
follow I'm going to recap it after we're
done but let's check out that update on
horse skate of course you know you know
your Horror Story my horse story
could you sell the horse I can't why not
I've had this one first 11 years and
Katie Katie Katie there's other horses
out there it doesn't even know your name
for horses for you on the other side
listen I want Katie to win yeah she's
here
in person I'm excited we're friends then
we like we hang out on Instagram all
right we're ready for the photo
look at George he even looks like me he
has my email here from high school to
tell me the dog doesn't even know my
name yes George the dog doesn't even
know your name it hurts as much as I
thought it was hurt so happy I can't go
do anything
George said I hope the Western Community
no no we're friends
oh thank you so much
wow what an interaction she stuck around
when she came to the meet and greet I
signed her book she gave me a picture of
a new horse she got named goose and she
nicknamed it George and this comes up
with her friend group as it does with
mine a week has not gone by with without
mentioning this situation and I signed
her book and I said the horse does know
your name and so he had a beautiful full
circle moment and I got an update from
her on where she's at with her debt-free
journey so when she called in she was
about 120 000 in debt making about 36
000 working for the USDA full-time and
couldn't find a side hustle in her rural
community the horse was bringing in 300
bucks a month it was injured she lost
that side hustle and so since then she
has paid 12 393 dollars and she has a
goal to pay off the remaining 113k in
the next two years because she got a new
side hustle painting interior houses oh
so she's already made like five grand
doing house painting and she enjoys it
it makes great money and so there was a
happy ending to this story that's great
and I think that's important to note
because you got a lot of hate for that
well here's why I went wrong and I
immediately regretted this after it came
out of my mouth when I said the horse
doesn't know your name because I know
horses are have like deep connection
soul level connections with their owners
and it's a beautiful thing and no the
people are like would you sell your dog
and I was like no my dog doesn't need a
farm now my dog was thousands of dollars
because they're luxury designer dogs
that's just what we like but no I would
not sell my dog I mean would you be sad
if somebody said they didn't know your
name my dog for sure doesn't know my
name my dogs are not the brightest
horses are way smarter I feel like
that's a healthy relationship with your
animal it is but I I do stand by the
fact that I mean she emailed into the
show and she was like this is a
prize-winning horse it's worth twenty
thousand dollars I was like oh no Katie
you're only making my point to sell a
horse and as we see it's not an ethical
moral thing if you sell a horse that's
fine if you're not a bad person if you
sell a horse but me telling someone to
sell the horse was apparently where the
line is it's probably the way you said
it the way I said it but here's why I
cared more about Katie's future than I
did her present day horse that was the
truth I wanted to see Katie win and
looking at the numbers on paper it hurt
my heart because I'm going oh my gosh
there's there's no way out of this thing
it's gonna take a decade or more to get
out of debt which is not okay and she's
young she's vibrant she has a whole life
ahead of her and that is why I gave her
that advice she did not take it she sold
she did sell one of her horses that was
kind of retired and bought this one this
newer one oh so of course people let me
tell you they are they are intense they
are die hard and they're willing to
spare no expense for their beloved
horses man so well and it's just it's
nice to see a full circle moment and to
see her acknowledge like hey you know
that was good advice but I think that
visceral reaction is pretty common
whenever you're trying to get out of
debt and there's a lot of things you
might be willing to sell there's a lot
of things that you're willing to part
with but there are certain things
especially with guys and trucks
yeah and you heard her at the end she
said you lit a fire under my butt and
whenever I'm making a decision my
friends go what would George say and so
I like that I got into her head in that
way just going what could you do get
creative what are you willing to
sacrifice so that the next 20 years of
your life don't suffer in mediocrity
that you can actually get to where you
want to go and not have anything hold
you back so that was the heart of it
Katie you're awesome if you're watching
out there we we are cheering you on this
debt-free journey and I can't wait for
your debt free scream please bring the
horse please
we're gonna need a cleanup crew on that
day oh gosh we'll be right back this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
calling from Jacksonville Florida
hey Alice welcome to the show
hi thank you guys so much for taking my
call thanks for calling how's it going
pretty good so I have a question that I
was wondering if you guys are able to
help me
um so I'm currently trying to figure out
what exactly would be the best option
for me at least in my situation
um my former job I had a 401k that I was
contributing to as well as with an
employer match and I'm no longer at that
job so since I'm no longer at that job I
was having a conversation with a
co-worker at my new job and they were
saying that since I no longer work there
I'm eligible to take that money out of
that 401k so I was wondering if that
would be a good idea for me to do to
help pay off my debt
you're I just who told you this and why
and do you trust them financially
because I wouldn't
more years of experience on me and they
said you can just take money from this
401k and do what you want with it
oh I know that it would be
for at that job yeah not only are you
gonna have to pay your income taxes on
that there's also going to be an early
withdrawal penalty of 10 percent
right so not only is that a very
expensive way to get money you're also
robbing the future growth of that money
in retirement
okay so this is a terrible idea yeah
bottom line wouldn't do that so let's
look at other ideas that are better so
you have some debt you're looking to pay
off correct yes how much yes
um roughly around 43 000. okay what kind
of debt is it
um 2000 is about in a car loan I have a
thousand and some change in a personal
loan
um around 8 000 credit cards and the
rest are my student loans okay
and what's your income
okay and what are you doing for work
um I work for like an I.T Staffing
Company
I.T Staffing okay and what is the
current timeline for you to pay this
debt down if you just use your income
um if I just used my income probably in
2025 like early 2025 late 2024. really
yes what did you you said your income is
fourteen hundred dollars a week
uh um or what's your annual income
well every two weeks but annually I'm
projected to make um not including
bonuses probably around like 45. okay
that's where the math isn't adding up
for me as to how you'd pay this off in
under two years
sure this is what the calculator said
when I didn't the numbers I do have a
side business as well so I do get a
little bit of income off of that so
sometimes like I sell things online and
then I have my own like I make candles I
have a candle business on the side as
well awesome so if we ramped both of
those things up how much more could you
add to your yearly income
she went really hard I would say
probably if I worked really really hard
especially with the candles because
there's a lot of money to be made there
um I said I could probably add at least
maybe this year alone maybe at least
five to ten thousand awesome and are you
investing with your new employer
um not that I'm aware of no
okay so I would encourage you to pause
all investing and just focus on this
debt and make that your one priority how
much money do you have in the bank
you have my thousand dollar under
emergency fund I do have maybe about 500
extra because I also planning on moving
out of the state okay moving out of the
states
yes out of the Florida moving out as
well moving to Maryland okay and is
there a job
um yes for a job I currently stay with
family so I can't really like stay here
forever and he has kids so I kind of
need to think of my next step so you're
gonna have to find a new job
um my job is in Maryland so I was more
than likely going to see if I could just
transfer okay awesome and do you want to
move to Maryland
um I do want to move out of Florida but
like Maryland just seemed like a nice
alternative I would just make sure like
as you think through that move
um cost of living in Maryland may be
quite a bit more than Florida so I would
just run some numbers on that because
you may want to wait a year or two until
this debt is tackled
um granted if you do want to move
especially if it's a raise then that
could be good but just also make sure to
factor in those extra things because you
said with family you got to move out but
you know perhaps you could find
somewhere in Florida on your own for the
time being
but I will say I I it's hard George
because I've been getting this question
quite a bit recently with the 401K
um option A lot of people are getting
tempted to pull it out and it is
tempting because you know with your
income you see that debt and it's like
man I could have this debt wiped out
quick it looks like a shortcut it looks
like a shortcut but but in the long run
especially when you factor in all the
growth you would lose it does not pay
off if I know it's not fun thinking
through you know paying this off and it
taking two years but in the long run
this will Roi so much more so Ellis
here's the math on this you have 43 000
in debt and let's say you're going to
pay this off in two years or less that
means you need to throw eighteen hundred
dollars total at the debt and you can do
this using the debt snowball method
which is smallest to largest regardless
of interest rate attack the smallest one
with everything you can throw at it pay
minimum payments on the rest and so if
you do that and you start bringing in
more income by selling stuff online
flipping stuff any money you can
scrounge up from the side hustles or
selling stuff you have laying around the
house uh obviously getting a raise maybe
even switching jobs that is going to
help you do this faster and then you can
get to the fully funded emergency fund
of three to six months that is your next
goal once we have the debt paid off and
you may want to sit down with a smart
faster Pro because you do have the 401K
and you've left jobs they can do a
rollover for you and figure out how to
invest that in the meantime yeah is this
a traditional 401k or is it a Roth
uh it should be a traditional 401K okay
so what you want to do is a direct
rollover to a traditional IRA that way
there are no penalties the you never see
the money it just goes straight into
another retirement account and then you
have options to invest way more than you
would have in your 401k
okay how does that sit with you
um that's as well like I did want to
know just because I knew that if I took
it out there would be like a lot of
penalties they were nice enough to at
least explain to me all the penalties
that I would have to say
um so the guy was like yeah do you want
to do it now I was just like
um let me call you back and I'll let me
talk to some professions who's the guy
like he's able to do this for you I'm
confused was it your employer no he was
just a co-worker he was just a co-worker
that was just talking oh okay all right
well hey I'm gonna gift you one-year
Financial Peace University and every
dollar to walk you through this process
the videos are going to be super
motivating watch all nine lessons start
that every dollar budget connect it to
your bank account start tracking the
transactions you're going to start to
feel the Steam and it's going to get
addictive you're gonna go okay wait we
have a thousand on the debt this month
how do we put 1200 the next month and
1500 the next month that's fun that's
fun all right well stay on the line
Austin will get you set up and I just
love that she heard that from the
co-worker it sounds tempting right it
sounds like ooh like I can have my debt
wiped out but then she had that gut
check and went you know what I'm gonna
talk to somebody else about this because
I think right now that we're in such a
culture where you know there's Tick Tock
people everywhere there's everybody
reading Financial articles there's so
many things where it's easy for a lot of
people to feel I feel like they know a
thing or two about money and it's like
the more I've listened and talked to
some people it's like the advice almost
seems right but then you're like wait a
minute well it always sounds good at
face value because right it feels like a
shortcut the problem with shortcuts is
it doesn't lead anywhere worth going to
because you end up further into debt or
staying in debt longer and so we're
seeing a lot of this right now Christina
people turning to helocs they're turning
to home equity loans they're turning to
401K loans 401K early withdrawals these
are all terrible options because we're
not actually fixing the behavior that
got us here all we're doing is trying to
pull it under the rug and go and it's
gone but it's not because now we've
created new problems for ourselves right
and it's stealing from the future when
you get in some of those savings
calculators and you see what you're
losing income pound growth it's like man
that's just it's not worth it but it is
so easy when your problem is right in
front of your face and you're like I've
got this debt and I want it gone it's
easy to want to take a shortcut and it's
like we want you to keep that anger and
that feeling of like I want this gone
immediately but do it the right way if
you feel like that's your only option
you don't have enough options keep
looking that's good that's good well
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books we'll be back soon this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsey show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life and your money I'm your host Ramsey
personality Christina Ellis joined today
by my co-host fellow Ramsay personality
and friend George Campbell we're taking
your calls at triple eight eight two
five five two two five hey if you like
the show please consider subscribing
leaving a review and sharing it with a
friend it helps us out and helps us
connect with more people who are trying
to figure out their money
all right let's go to the show through
the phone first up we have Ethan calling
from San Francisco California
hey Ethan welcome to the show
hey guys how are you doing we're doing
well how can we help
yeah so I am 22 years old
um been graduating this may with my
bachelor's um debt-free congrats and
thank you
um I got accepted to law school which
has always been a dream of mine so
that's man that's big
yes thank you very much
um I have a good amount of money saved
um for school
um and my options are I could either
um put all of this money towards law
school and graduate law school debt free
um or I could go and take a student loan
on uh for school and put all of that
money towards uh 25 to 30 percent down
payment on a house or condo since I'm
you know interested in owning property
um so kind of wanted to just get your
opinion on either which one I should do
or if you have any other ideas well I
feel such mixed emotions right now
because on one hand I'm like yes you
graduated debt free and you have all
this money saved up that's amazing but
then hearing you say maybe I'll take out
a student loan and buy a house makes me
go wait no
no you have done so well so far let's
not be stupid now here's how I look at
the season imagine graduating law school
debt free and you get to choose the
employer because you're not desperate to
pay back your student loan payments and
have to choose some entry-level law job
just to cover the bills because now you
have these huge student loan payments
after taking a few hundred thousand out
and so I love this idea of you
graduating debt free you're gonna have a
great income you're gonna be able to
cover rent and once you graduate debt
free all of your lawyer friends who are
struggling to make their payments and
cover the mortgage and they're trying to
look good instead you now use your
newfound income to save up that down
payment and get this house and walk into
it with peace
and it would be a little bit different
so let's say that you were unsure about
law school you know I'd have a lot more
questions about you know maybe you go
into the world and start working and buy
your house and all of that but the fact
that this has been your dream you have
the money saved up like you have done
everything right up to this point so
finishing out you know all the schooling
that you want to do debt free
how much money are we talking is this
going to cost
uh I have a 185 000 saved back up okay
so how how did this happen you're 22
years old 185 saved give us the details
yeah um I uh in high school I co-founded
a company startup uh with a couple
friends
um and that actually exited last year uh
my portion of that was
um around 160 000 after taxes
um and then the other 25 I've just saved
over the years oh my goodness you're
like boy wonder over here way to go man
it's incredible yeah I'm I'm so
impressed and you know if I'm in your
shoes I'm going to law school debt free
and I'm buying a house after and you're
obviously brilliant I'm I wouldn't be
surprised if you came up with a new
company in the next two years and had
the down payment you know after you
graduated from law school but obviously
you're going to be earning law school
money you know lost school graduate
money here soon so it's like you're
going to be able to save up that money
for a down payment quick really fast and
you're 22. you've got so much time on
your side even if you're a homeowner at
27 instead of 22.
um you know I'm renting I'm going to
stay free right now while you focus on
law school and not have to worry about
home ownership and maintenance and
repairs and all that stuff that comes
along with it you just get to be free
and have that flexibility hey Ethan hang
on the line Austin's gonna pick up and
we'll get you a copy of baby steps
millionaires because it is obvious that
you are heading that direction keep it
up man keep making the good decisions
don't get tempted by the Allure of
trying to rush things like you were on
an awesome car I want to be like Ethan
when I grow up
can you imagine at 22 being like I
exited a company in the last year I'm
like I was an idiot up until about right
now and so I'm just really impressed by
that guy I mean I mean but you are doing
well George sure I wasn't exiting
companies at 21 years old I was
collecting debt I mean that is that is
like my dream right now with trying to
get to the younger generation is to be
able to one talk to parents to have you
know encourage them to have these many
conversations but also talk to students
because you know if you can get in their
head early and they can get passionate
about their own money journey and get
excited it's like the things they can do
it's just incredible I was actually uh
working on writing yesterday and doing
some math on the difference between if
somebody uh took out a student loan and
what that would look to look like to pay
it off versus if that they took that
same amount of money and invested it and
it was like mind-blowing it was like
something like if they took the 267
dollar payment that they would have been
paying for 20 years on a student loan
and they instead invested that money for
20 years they'd have two hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars saved up in 20
years versus the person with a student
loan would have paid back sixty three
thousand dollars so the person with a
student loan would have zero dollars at
the end of that twenty years and the
other person had two hundred and fifteen
thousand dollars saved up from the same
payment and then if you back that out
and you go okay what if the 215 000 just
sat in a savings account without any
more you know additions to it and they
just waited for 20 more years they'd
have over a million dollars saved wow
just based off of what that person paid
in student loan payments so it's like
when you see that math it's just
mind-blowing and it's so exciting
thinking about talking to the younger
generation because it's like if you can
grasp this early on if you can have this
click you can become a baby steps
millionaire early in life and that is
just awesome I think you and I we both
made our fair share of money mistakes
and there's things we didn't know in our
20s where we're like oh man if we had
just known that and it's like young
people listening parents with kids
listening you guys have the potential to
do this early in life you don't have to
necessarily go through the University of
Hard Knocks like so many of us have been
through and so it's just exciting
hearing about people like Ethan and just
knowing that we have the power to
influence this next Generation where you
know they can have a great financial
future and become millionaires early in
life well I'm thinking that these
Generations are getting it because now
they see all their friends broke because
of these two loan payments hoping and
wishing for someone to do something
about it shaking their fists at the
clouds and at Biden or they can go I'm
gonna figure out a way around this I'm
gonna go to a community college I'm
going to look for those scholarships I'm
going to work part-time and now the
parents that went through FPU are going
I'm going to help my kid go to college
debt free and so I'm hoping fingers
crossed praying that we see an entire
generation that goes we're done with
student loan debt we're not taking this
crap from the student loan companies
anymore oh that's so good that's my hope
let's go
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
taking your calls at AAA 825-5225
all right George so I leaned into it I
started doing Frugal February on
Instagram yes
people are loving it so we did the no
spend challenge in January no it's been
January Frugal February and as I was
looking for ideas for Frugal February I
came across a post where someone saved
24 deodorant butts to melt them down
into one full stick
so they saved there's a name for the end
of deodorant apparently deodorant butts
is what we're calling them deodorant
butts it's a thing it's a thing like I
could Google that and I wouldn't get
fired or go to the HR office I mean I
don't know
but okay so they saved and so in looking
at Frugal stuff I'm like this person
saved four dollars but wasted a bunch of
time in storage space like that's dumb
yeah I feel like I could have made more
in that time than four dollars exactly
I'm like I would rather you go out and
spend five hours working and make a
hundred bucks then spend five hours
scraping out deodorant from the tube and
trying to make it you know something
something useful a lot of effort so one
of the things I'm saying is like be
smart about how you're being Frugal like
you'll see a lot of things online about
different ways to be frugal and some of
them are good and some of them are dumb
and so trying to discern you know what
is a good Frugal thing to do is
important so I found an article with a
bunch of unusual money-saving tips and I
want to get your feedback on them
Georgia not gonna be good I want your
yay or nay okay all right the first one
I actually think is pretty good marry
someone frugal
yay yay number two don't waste money on
toilet paper use newspaper junk mail
bills and more hard pass that is the
hardest nay you can get I'm naying like
a horse over here on that one why no
question newspaper that can't be good
for you hygiene wise okay what about
this one double your toilet paper by
separating it
no my parents didn't immigrate to this
country for me to use one ply life is
too short and that apply is too thin
Christina that's disgusting
paper usage to two sheets per wipe why
are these all tp-related money hacks
it's like they know you who's limiting
themselves strong feelings on toilet
paper okay what about this one cut your
own hair no no unless you work remote
and never leave the house
now females maybe can pull it off yeah
maybe I think there's a lot of people
post covid that are yay on that I can't
just like take a flow beat to this
Christina this is it's a it's a Leonardo
DaVinci I mean it's a sculpture you have
very specialized hair I will admit that
I don't know that I could do that all
right this is a Michelangelo next one is
to plant fake flowers in your garden
they last for years require no
maintenance are and are in full bloom in
the winter
I would argue just don't do any of that
and just don't have plants if you're not
going to plant them you look so
horrified I don't think you're HOA okay
a fake house plant inside I can get
behind that okay for the looks what
about okay this next one is one man's
trash is another man's treasure it says
there's no shame in going through the
neighbor's trash once it's been placed
outside for collection it's public
domain and you can pick up some great
things that other people just don't want
or need anymore if I saw my neighbor
going through my trash I would be
calling the cops immediately so don't do
that on George's problem don't even try
it that's got to be against HOA rules in
my neighborhood disgusting what are you
looking for in someone's trash
I mean I'm not gonna lie there's been a
few times where I passed some trash on
the road and saw like something there's
like a TV on the curb and you think you
can fix it up that's one thing but to go
through their filthy garbage to hope you
find something no yeah that's rough okay
this one says take a vacation quote
unquote at Christmas to save money on
gifts just let everyone know you're
going away for the holidays and we'll
exchange gifts when you return then lay
low buy all your presents in the after
Christmas sales for way less and have a
very happy new year
so this is their money hack flee the
country and let your family forget about
you never have to buy my gift again hey
but you'll get a good sale after
Christmas insane okay what about this
one cover your floor with carpet samples
how about that for your new house it
says you can pick them up cheap and
sometimes free
um at hardware stores just put them in
squares and glue them down just random
loose samples all over the floor I guess
I care too much about aesthetic and my
own quality of life to do that okay I'm
above that you're above that okay uh
this one's really strange I think this
one I'm just gonna go ahead and say it's
a nay before I read it but donate your
clothes then buy them back the local
charity will clean them for you and you
can just pop back in a week buy the ones
you want for a few bucks it's cheaper
than a dry cleaner
okay the idea that me buying my clothes
back after I gave them for free is a
money hack might be the stupidest one on
this list so far
okay and also you're hoping they clean
them right you've been to Goodwill that
smell ain't the smell of freshly dry
cleaned clothes
true
on the hair back bandwagon and you're
cutting your own hair how about this one
old hair makes great stuffing for
pillows
I might throw up on air for the first
time
take old hair and stuff it into a pillow
yeah
this is what the actual suggestion is
even worse it says if you don't cut your
own hair the local barber shop or hair
salon will gladly give you the cutting
from the floor listen BuzzFeed has gone
too far it's soft free and biodegradable
oh I cringe
sleep on it like oh
okay the last one let's end on a decent
one it's flesh with less water place a
common house brick inside a plastic bag
and seal it repeat the seal with another
bag just to make it super waterproof
because you don't want brick corrosion
put this in your toilets tank and it
will save you money on your water bill
over yours I'm not I'm not doing any of
this I don't think plumbers would agree
I think it's probably bad for your your
plumbing system in your toilet to do
things like that there's probably a
reason why the tank is that size yeah
I'm gonna go with I don't know just I'd
rather get a side hustle versus do any
of this insane stuff just budget I'd
rather create a subscription than have
to use my own hair in a pillow that just
like makes me cringe so bad and I think
it's so important to highlight because I
have seen so many people trying to save
money and doing it in unwise ways there
are great ways to do it that you know
it's worth the investment and there are
other times where it's probably best to
just get a side hustle listen I love the
Amish but I'm not making my own soap
anytime soon you sure I'm not doing it
well but the thing is too is like
there's actually side hustles that you
can create that you know you make soap
for other people and it makes money you
want to make your fancy soaps yeah the
Old Goat soap the Old Goat soap oh my
goodness all right let's take a call we
have Ben calling from Colorado Springs
Colorado hey Ben welcome to the show
hey Christina and George good to talk to
you and it's a hard pass on all of those
thank you Ben good man good call so we
like some direction both my wife and I
work for the same company we're looking
at retirement
um in the the data set four here we're
currently under except three again we
had a emergency in the fall and we had
to go back to selling that baby step
three
so our um employer contributes 10
percent of our income uh into the 403 b
and it's not a match
so we're not sure really what to do
about that if we're going to treat it
like a match or if we want to just call
that icing on the cake
um sorry is that from your own paycheck
no okay so just this is basically free
money they're putting into this account
it's free money it's like a match but
it's not a match got it it doesn't
matter how much you put in they're going
to put in 10 percent
they're putting in 10 okay our income is
just North of 92 000. soared about
thirteen thousand eight maybe fourteen
thousand and we have both traditional
and Roth options within this 403d so
we're not sure if we're supposed to
do 10 to be like a match or do all 15 in
the Roth or a combination thereof
if I'm in your shoes I'm gonna do 15
into the Roth each of us
that's the simplest way to go about this
okay and you have the funds to do that
right once you're out of this uh baby
step three
yeah we should be there starting in May
I love it I mean that's essentially 25
going in and your 15 is after tax it's
going to grow tax-free you can withdraw
it tax free and so I like that plan
that's going to only give you more money
in retirement and help you guys retire
baby steps millionaires way to go
ten percent that's pretty incredible
right that's not mandatory from my own
paycheck they're just giving it to me I
love it we'll be back this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five well guess
what day it is Christina what hump day
is that a camel joke guys is that what
that was about I take offense to that as
someone with the last name camel but I
appreciate it as well well done well
hump day means tomorrow's Thursday which
means it's time for our Building Wealth
Event in Austin Texas guys if you've
never experienced our Building Wealth
live event you don't want to miss this
the excitement the life-changing
inspiration encouragement from Dave
Ramsey Dr John deloney Ken Coleman and
Jade warshaw it's the reason these
events sell out including tomorrow's
night uh tomorrow night's Event in
Austin Well in a world where you can
literally rent a chicken so you don't
have to buy eggs at the grocery store
it's as insane as it sounds it can feel
like you can't get ahead with money let
alone invest and save for retirement but
the truth is you can do this stuff and
we're going to show you how at our
Building Wealth live event
so we've got two more dates this spring
where you can still join us Salt Lake
City on April 24th with Dave Ramsey
myself Rachel Cruz and Christina Ellis
that'll be your first one my first one
excited for that and then Anaheim
California to round out the spring Tour
on May 2nd with Dave Ramsey Dr John
deloney Ken Coleman and Christina Ellis
and like I said Indianapolis Austin both
sold out so don't miss your chance to
get tickets for Salt Lake City and
Anaheim today before they're gone
ramseysolutions.com
events all right let's go back to the
phones next up we have Tim calling from
Cleveland Ohio hey Tim welcome to the
show
how you doing hey doing well how are you
doing
I'm doing well as well let's how can we
help
um so I'm currently renting with my
girlfriend and we're looking at buying a
house but she's also pregnant so I was
just wondering if we should continue
renting or buy a house and which college
phone I should open up for our soon to
be a child
well tell us a little bit more about
your situation do you have any debt
right now
uh I I have that I have a sixteen
thousand dollar car loan and a twenty
thousand dollar personal loan from
college
okay and how about her and then
she has ten thousand in uh federal
student loan
Okay so
we're probably just gonna go ahead and
take buying a house off the table right
now uh the first thing we're gonna say
is tackle that debt and I know
especially with a baby coming into the
world there's so many thoughts of you
know trying to get settled down and Nest
that's such a natural desire to want to
Nest but in the long run we really want
this debt gone and the financial
stability to be there so do you have any
money in the bank right now
uh yes so she has 80 000.
oh
okay what about you
I just paid off 30 000 of debt so I used
my savings to pay off half of my student
debt so that's why I'm down to 20.
you're down to 20 000 in savings
no no no in student debt I used all my
savings to pay off my debt oh so
yeah so I'm also active duty military so
we would use the VA loan
okay all right and how old are you two
30. go 30 years old are you familiar
with the baby steps
uh I've glanced at him I'm not familiar
enough now no that's okay we're gonna
we'll walk George will walk you through
them really quick uh which will kind of
help frame what we do here at Ramsey and
kind of the approach which I know may
seem counter-intuitive especially when
you're in that nesting mode and you're
wanting to settle down and get a house
but uh I promise you this has worked for
millions of people and it seems like the
slow route but it gets you where you
want to go yeah so have you guys uh
combined finances are they separate
separate and you're just kind of
splitting the bills down the middle
yes okay good so let's keep them
separate so all the steps I talk about
she's gonna do it her on her own you're
gonna do it on your own uh we don't want
to co-mingle these finances uh because
that that'll create a headache down the
road so baby step one thousand dollar
starter emergency fund do you have a
thousand dollars
yes I I spend so currently I put 2 700
towards just paying down my debt every
month okay but you have a thousand in
the bank sitting there
yes okay and then baby step two we're
paying down all of our debt using the
debt snowball smallest to largest
balance regardless of the interest rate
which means what debt is next for you
what's the next smallest loan you have
smallest one would be the car sixteen
thousand what's the car worth
uh I just got it appraised pretty much
what I owe on it okay and what's your
income
my income is eighty nine thousand and it
goes up 20 grand next year awesome well
that's great that'll help having that
bigger shovel to clean up this mess so
we're gonna clean up the car loan and
that just leaves you with the personal
loan
yes and so you've got 36 000 in debt you
make 89 about to be making over a
hundred how quickly can you pay off 36
000 with focused intensity
I put 2007 towards debt so and that
gives me spending money as well like I
could I could definitely put more down
Okay so we're talking a little over a
year a year and a half
probably yes okay and once we're there
we're going to build up that emergency
fund now obviously we have a baby on the
way so you may need to pause in order to
save up a bunch of money and it's good
that she has that savings have you guys
talked about how you're gonna figure
this out financially with the baby
uh yes How's that gonna work
so she she has a job too we're both
military we both she makes more money
than I do okay
how long have you guys been uh dating
three years okay what are y'all thinking
about for the future are you thinking
about marriage
so what is kind of uh the hold off from
doing it right now whenever you're kind
of thinking through all this money stuff
thinking about buying a house
um where does it fit in the timeline
uh we have no issue like doing it now
um
I was just deployed so I just got back
well I'm I'm thinking go ahead and do it
especially with baby coming for that
baby to come into the world with two
committed parents and to truly start
this financial Journey on the same page
would be amazing and it changes the
numbers here when you have dual incomes
all focused towards the same goal
because now it's our money which means
that 80 000 in savings can help you
clear that debt tomorrow instead of a
year and a half from now which then
frees up your income to help cover
expenses get the emergency fund where it
needs to be start investing and save up
that down payment for the house
okay you'll get to that house a lot
faster if you get married and do this
the right way
and congratulations this is exciting
exciting this is a very exciting time I
know that it's a lot to process and you
immediately want to start jumping into
getting all the info and all the things
that's a lot it's a lot and don't invest
for for college until we are at baby
step five which means we have no more
debt we you may want to save for a house
before then you want to be investing 15
then we can open up you know a 529 plan
for the baby and start putting on a
little bit of money for that you got
plenty of time on that side let's focus
on our own personal finances first yeah
hey Tim hang on currently low sorry no
go ahead
should I currently lower my tsp I would
lower it to zero until we clean up this
mess of debt okay and temporarily and it
will also light a fire under you because
you're missing out on investing and I
get I can tell you love investing I love
that for you but when you go down to
zero it's going to create more margin in
your budget because you have more income
in the bank to throw at this debt which
is only going to speed up the process
okay thank you you got it man hey thanks
for your service Tim hang on the line as
our gift to you we will get you into
Financial Peace University Austin will
pick up and get that for you we are
wishing you well in this yes go go
through it together as a team there's
nothing like it Christina when you have
a spouse who is on board and you guys
are headed the same direction with the
same vision the same goals it speeds up
the process so much faster yes it's kind
of like The Frugal tip marry someone
Frugal marry somebody that carries about
that cares about money whenever you guys
get on the same page about money it is
such a game changer well then there's
less money fights because now we're not
arguing about hey I thought we said you
weren't gonna it just becomes no we have
the same goal which means we're both not
eating out we're both not frivolously
spending we're both pausing investing
it's not it doesn't become a tit-for-tat
situation yeah and it's fine if you all
are totally different in how you view
money I think a lot of people you know
the nerd finds us and then they start
shoving it in the face of their spouse
and they're like
I'm not actually wow I know a lot of
people don't realize that but I am more
the free spirit nerd spender she's the
free spirit saver it's a weird
relationship but we make it work that's
awesome and a lot of times Opposites
Attract so you know it's great even if
your spouse is kind of resistant at
first and they're like I don't know
about this whole you know money thing I
don't know if I want to talk about money
money give them time they can get their
wings PPU helps you get there yes we'll
be right back this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsay show our
scripture of the day comes from First
Corinthians 15 58 be steadfast immovable
always abounding in the work of the Lord
our quote comes from Rosa Parks stand
for something or you will fall for
anything today's Mighty Oak is
yesterday's nut that held its ground
love that that's powerful all right
let's go to the phones up next we have
Heather calling from Portland Oregon hey
Heather welcome to the show
hey thank you thanks for calling how can
we help
so I went to a credit union to open up a
bank account and you let me know that
someone else's name is on my social
security number and my credit report so
it sounds like they stole my identity
and I'm not really sure what to do about
it and I just wanted to call you guys
and find out when did you find out about
this
uh probably about three or four weeks
ago I was out of town and that's when I
found out and have what all have they
done thus far have they opened up new
cards or do you know how far the damage
is at this point
I don't I need to check my credit report
yes so sorry that's happened
that's a great first step is to pull
your you can do that uh for free don't
pay to have this done I believe the
site's annualcreditreport.com you can
pull them from all three bureaus for
free so that would be a great first step
on top of freezing your accounts so you
can place a fraud alert on those
accounts and freeze them so that no one
else can open up anything under your
name or social security number
yeah I would get on that like as soon as
you get off the phone with us I would
not let any other time pass have you
filed any kind of police report
no I wasn't really sure what to do okay
so is there any proof that there has
been Financial harm to you that they've
actually
um I mean because what they could do
this happened to me about a decade ago
Heather someone opened up an ATT account
and Verizon account across the country
using my name my social security number
racked up 1700 bucks on both and then I
had debt collectors calling me
and so it didn't actually cost me money
I just had debt collectors coming after
me for accounts that I never opened and
so that could be the case with you where
they're opening these accounts they're
spending money on them they're not going
to pay them and all of a sudden you have
debt collectors Coming For You Down the
Line
yeah I'm not sure what they've done I
haven't
um I haven't heard from anyone
um so I'm not really sure
yeah I wouldn't again I wouldn't wait to
hear from anyone I would be super
proactive in this situation because this
is one of those things where literally
every day that passes you know they have
the potential to do more harm
um with your with your information so I
would literally as soon as you get off
the phone and start working through the
steps now and we have a really good
article on it at ramsaysolutions.com
that we can link in the show notes yes
it's called what to do if your identity
is stolen and this is an article I
worked on to help folks like you who
find themselves in this situation and
there's about 12 steps you can take to
be proactive and make sure that no more
harm is done that may include you know
updating your passwords and usernames it
may include closing any of those fake
accounts that were opened in your name
contacting your utility providers
another account fraud departments to let
them know about this your bank's fraud
department so there's a lot of steps you
can take and it's frustrating and it
takes a lot of time and it's one of the
reasons we recommend ID Theft Protection
we all have them as team members here
through Xander thanks to thanks to Uncle
Dave because they help clean up this
mess and do the work because it can be
hours and hours and so maybe worth
contacting them as well and say hey can
you guys help with this I don't know how
that works after the fact but I would
look into that for sure so yeah hang on
the line Austin will get you that
article what to do if your identity is
stolen and we'll put it in the YouTube
description and podcast show notes for
anyone interested in that well for
everybody listening who's worried about
ID theft you know you can go to
ramseysolutions.com click on trusted
services and you can connect with Xander
as well to get that ID theft protection
I know I sleep so much better at night
knowing that I have that for the just in
case it's one of the things that you
never think is going to happen to you
but the stats are pretty crazy I don't
remember the exact number of ID thefts
that happen per year but I remember when
I read it I was like and uh when I had
identity theft hit I had just started at
Ramsay and so luckily we had that in
place so I was like hey I'm gonna
contact Xander about this and they were
super helpful in walking me through
here's the documents we need here's what
you can help with then they would run
with it they'd send me updates on where
where things stood they got the accounts
closed and it was I mean it was still a
nightmare to deal with but I can't
imagine doing it all on my own the hours
it would take that's rough so well
protect yourselves folks yeah I I just
from then on freeze my all the credit
bureaus just freeze your accounts so
that no one can open anything in your
name
it's smart there you go all right up
next we have Joelle calling from Dallas
Texas hey Joelle welcome to the show
hey y'all my question
um is regarding a home so my mom
recently passed and she left her home to
seven children my mom was so great and
she moved here to the United States from
the Democratic Republic of Congo and she
built this house and she passed last
month and her seven children are heirs
to the home so I just wanted to get some
advice from the team on what we should
do with the home whether we should sell
it or we should rent it
well I'm so sorry for your loss but it
sounds like she was an amazing woman
that's amazing oh I can hear it in your
voice I just don't I mean even just for
raising seven children you should win a
Nobel Peace Prize that's incredible
seriously what a woman um so tell tell
me about the relationship with the
siblings is everybody on the same page
everybody you know getting along well
everyone's getting along well
um everyone's on the same page I'm I'm
the one in the mindset that we should
sell it we should sell it only because
there's a lot of us and you know the
maintenance to keep up with the house I
don't know if everyone would be willing
to chip in when there is trouble so that
is a worry of mine and so you're saying
you want to sell it but it sounds like
other people don't what's kind of the
consensus on that that side
um just because it's Monumental right
it's a symbolism of what she's built
here in America for us so how many years
of your siblings don't want to sell the
house
uh there is about really two to three of
us and then the other four are strongly
for keeping it
so if they did keep it what would they
what would they do with it would they
rent it would somebody live in it what's
kind of the plan yeah they so they would
they would rent it to someone find a
landlord also find a property manager to
kind of manage it so that we won't have
to but my biggest fear with that is you
know what if someone doesn't that the
tenant does not pay the rent and that's
up to us to take care of it if they
break down that that's up to us to think
of it and I love my siblings but we've
also are not the best in chipping in
especially when there's so many of us
yeah and how would that work would it be
all seven of you would stay owners and
and be splitting the profit seven ways
is that kind of how they Envision that
yep correct well is there anybody any of
the siblings that want to keep the house
that could basically buy the rest of you
out
see that actually that's a good point I
I was thinking about that and I want but
I currently have a home of my own and my
wife and I are on beach step six trying
to pay off our own homework so like you
know I'd have to take out another loan
to basically buy them out
one it sounds like you don't actually
want to keep it you're on the side of
selling it so would perhaps one of the
ones that strongly wants to keep it yeah
they would buy you out by buying your
share of it
right so they would have to give you you
know how much is the home worth
um it's about two two fifty okay
okay so it's it's a doable amount
potentially for one of the seven of you
yeah
I mean that would that would kind of you
know it's it's a a bit of a creative
solution to kind of solve keeping it's
the keeping it in the family you know it
solves that but it also gets the rest of
you who don't actually want to be part
of it out of it
is this still in Probate or is it
without probate
um it's not within probate yet so that's
the step that we're we're going through
right now and then who's the executor
um it's probably gonna be my older
brother okay because they may have more
control in the situation if they're the
executor but we need to come to an
agreement of what this looks like even
if it means hey we're going to buy out
some of these co-heirs
um because depending on the legal
situation which I would still talk to an
estate attorney if you haven't already
and figure out what the legal
implications are what can the executor
decide to do who has a say who has a
vote but man that could be messy if
everyone disagrees yeah and if I'm in
your shoes I do not want to be renting
out a house with seven of my other
siblings hoping that we all figure out
all the profits over the next several
years that sounds yeah messy and like it
could be a recipe for a lot of family
arguments in the future and wishing you
the best man so sorry for your loss all
right that puts this hour of the Ramsay
show and the in the books thanks to all
the guys in the booth Austin Ben James
Zack and Andrew and to you America for
tuning in we'll be back soon this is the
Ramsey Show oh hey it's Christina Ellis
if you love the show and want to dive
deeper on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]